if the U.S has one of the less corrupt
governments on Earth which I don't know
for sure if it does or not but I know
there are places that are a real mess
but if if the US does have a less
corrupt government and that's the way
that business is handled uh among you
know someone that was the vice president
who'd been in in DC for 45 years at that
at that point or whatever then you know
that just imagine the rest of the world
yeah the rest of the world's a mess and
you know Ukraine is a absolute pigsty
because everyone knows that Ukraine is
is ex well everyone is aware of the the
root the the story or narrative that
Ukraine is one of the more most corrupt
governments in the world 100 and and I I
don't know but I would assume Russia is
too but like
um that that's why you know it's it's so
crazy that like we're involved in this
war in the first place because we're
talking about two very corrupt
um very authoritarian which we can get
into like you know pre-wars zelinski